welcome again everyone to my talk CDC
stream processing with Apache Flink
um yeah there will be some overlap with
the presentation before but I basically
splitted the um the presentation to
three parts so people that have never
heard of Link before will get some
introduction to Flink then I will also
introduce you to Flink SQL so Flink SQL
and then I will dive really really deep
into the engine because I believe only
if you also have seen the engine from
the inside you know how how powerful it
actually is
so uh quickly also about me uh so I have
basically two parts in in my CV an open
source part in the career part open
source wise I am a long time uh
committer
um of Apache fling I joined the project
before it actually became part of the
factory software Foundation I'm a PMC a
member also among the top uh
contributors suddenly I don't know what
I did
um also top one contributor according to
editions maybe I did a couple of
refactorings there
um and I'm among the core architects of
Link SQL career-wise I was part of a
startup called Data Artisans which got
acquired to Alibaba later
um then it was got renamed to the very
car last year we founded emerok to make
Flink ready for the cloud native era and
emerald got acquired by confluent early
this year
so let's get started what is the patchy
fling
um in general before we really start
talking about the battery fling I think
we should start talking about stream
processing in general because regardless
uh which vendor or which software you
look at you always have similar problems
to solve because stream processing is
sometimes a bit more complex than than
batch processing and batch processing
you're starting the job it runs for some
time and then it ends and in stream
processing usually you have to deal with
certain building blocks that are
required to to create pipelines and on
this slide you can see um the the four
building blocks that um I have have
identified so first of all we need
streams right so we want to deal with
streams you you want to create a
pipeline out of it you maybe want to
distribute streams so that you can scale
out and maybe you have the complex logic
that takes a lot of time so you want to
distribute the work across across the
cluster you want to join streams from
time to time sometimes there is a
mainstream and a side Stream So you want
to maybe enrich the mainstream with data
from the side stream sometimes you want
to have a dynamic rule engine or
something like that so maybe you have a
mainstream and a Control stream and
through the controls stream you might
might want to stream parameters in there
or in entire machine learning model and
of course if there is a bug in your
logic exam times you also want to
reprocess replay the stream to to also
process historical data another building
block is time when we talk about time on
one side we want to make progress but on
the other side sometimes you need to
wait for something but you don't want to
wait endlessly so you might also want to
time out at some point when we want to
wait then there is also some
synchronization involved because maybe
the streams are progressing in different
speed but again sometimes you just want
to fast forward process historical data
so time should also work when you fast
forward and also when you replay
uh one of the big strengths that have
link has regards to State
um you will see that in a second so
state is um is a very important building
block uh when you want to store
something so that can be a machine
learning model that can be a record for
which you wait for the second record to
join it maybe you want to buffer data
until some end transaction event comes
in maybe you want to Cache some data in
state because you don't want to query
the database all the time because that
would increase the latency
in some point you might grow State up to
the orders of terabytes and at some
point also due to gdpr restrictions or
so you also want to expire State and
whenever there is State involved the
question arises like how do we how do we
deal with fault tolerance how can we um
we can and we create snapshots of my
state so you need some backup
functionality you need version
durable storage you might may want to
Fork your state so that you can play
around with it in a in a staging
environment or you do some a b testing
of New Logic and again you want to time
travel maybe and also want to restore
snapshots
um if that is necessary
and the question often comes up like
okay uh so fling supports all of these
building blocks but but what makes
things so so unique and um like I always
try to explain it with this uh with this
diagram here so whenever you develop a
thing a pipeline basically it's the same
as if you would draw some diagram some
deck on on a whiteboard so first you
declare some sources some operations
like a normalization step a filter step
a join step and a sink
Flink under the hood will take care of
the parallelism for you so you never
have to deal with parallelism in the API
itself usually you just Define the
pipeline declaratively and then Flink
will scale out with multiple subtasks it
will take care of the serialization and
you never have to deal with threading or
with network serialization and stuff
like that
and now comes the important part that
link that makes Flink unique Flink has
um like things tries to put State local
to each subtest so to each thread
um and that means that first of all the
state access is very efficient because
you don't have to go to a remote system
for for looking up State and this state
can also scale in and scale out with the
operator so if a parallelism of 100 is
needed the scale will scale at the state
will scale uh with the with the topology
and
um yeah and of course like then um
events travel through through the
topology and from time to time fling uh
will create so-called checkpoints to
store the entire like a consistent
snapshot of the entire topology into a
durable storage like S3 or some other
distributed file system
so what is Apache link used for in
general
um very a big variety of of use cases
for transactions for logs iot event
interactions you can connect it with
Kafka or Kinesis you can also read from
files you can read from databases and
yeah also like use case wise analytics
data integration ETL use cases and also
event driven application are possible
because you don't need to Only Store
some values instead you can also put a
state machine into state so that allows
you to have like more event-driven
applications implemented in Flink and I
heard even some people created social
networks with Apache fling and doing all
the heavy listing lifting of counting
the events the comments the likes and
and whatever a lot of stuff is possible
with the stream processor and yes output
systems again we have messaging systems
files applications or other key value
stores
so let's talk about the apis in Flink so
under the hood there is a dedicated data
flow runtime this is the foundation for
all upper layers so in the Petri flank
and on top of that there is like a low
level stream operator API but we don't
need to get into the details here the
important piece is there are two main
horses in in fling there is the data
stream API which goes directly against
the stream operator API and there is the
table and SQL API which is like a
relational API where also there is a
planner an Optimizer in the in the
middle and yeah and then we have other
apis but I won't go into the details
here I want to focus on the two main
apis for in the following slides
so this is an example of the data stream
API it's basically just instantiating
like the execution environment and it
sets the runtime mode to streaming but
we also support batch mode by the way
and yeah we are just creating a stream
from like from one to three elements and
then we are just executing this on a
cluster retrieving the results back to
the client and printing the results
um to the local console it's not a very
useful pipeline but maybe you just it
serves to get the concepts so the
important piece for for the for the data
stream apis is first of all it exposes
the building blocks that I mentioned
earlier so you can arbitrarily Define an
operator topology using some abstracted
methods like map process and connect
um your you can decide how your business
logic is written in user-defined
functions you can use arbitrary user
defined record types that flow between
the operators and the interesting thing
here talking about CDC processing now
um conceptually the data stream API is
always an append only or insert only
lock so when we are printing this
pipeline uh or the to the to the console
what we see as an output is just one two
three so it's always just insertions
now let's have a look at uh the table
and SQL API so we always sometimes we
just say SQL API sometimes we say only
table API in the say in the in the end
it's the same they are just using
different endpoints I would say so you
instantiate uh the the table API with
table environment and then you can
decide do I want to do it
programmatically with Java docs with the
IDE help like pressing the dot and list
all the methods that you want to choose
from or or you use a standard NC SQL
syntax and in the end again we're doing
the same as in the previous example we
are executing and then we are printing
printing locally
so compared to data stream API we are
abstracting the building blocks for
stream processing
um we cannot largely
decide how the operator topology looks
like this will be done by the planner
and Optimizer the business logic is
declared not not explicitly mentioned so
it's up for the planner how to actually
execute this whole thing and internally
there are internal records flow between
the operators and yeah externally there
is also a road type that you can use in
table API and now comes the important
piece here conceptually we are working
with tables
but there is actually a lot of change
lock and CDC logic under the hood so
also when we are printing this uh to the
console you will immediately see that
there is actually a column that is
actually not in the schema of the table
which is an operation column so the
output is also a a change lock when you
print it for debug debugging purposes um
to the to the console
and sometimes people ask me so do I
always have to use SQL or what happens
if I want to do something more
sophisticated and the answer is you can
mix and match those two apis together so
you can start for example in in a SQL
um or and use the SQL connectors and
then you can go to data stream API to do
some more complicated stuff and then you
can go back
um yeah to table API and SQL for the
next processing and so on so you can go
back and forth without any issues and or
not much overhead
um so let's let's talk really about
changelog stream processing
um so in Flink basically we we view
everything as a stream so the entire
world of data processing is kind of a
stream for us and it's just about like
how do we actually process this stream
of changes so
if you think about it in general if your
business would be out of if you would go
out of business then the stream would
basically stop
um sometimes you also just want to have
the project be stopped or like you just
want to cut the stream into pieces to
process individual
um
intervals
so we only this we only distinguish
between bounded and unbounded streams
and inflink and
um even a batch scenario for us just
means that um it's just a special case
that we can use in the runtime to make
it a bit more efficient so batch
processing sometimes can be more
efficient if you know that the data is
ending and you can sort and you can
reuse the Sorting in batch mode but yeah
in general screen processing is very
flexible you can start in the now and
process the future you can start
somewhere in the past to the now or even
yeah whatever to um to the Future
then the next question is how do I
actually work with streams in fling SQL
and I already mentioned it before you
actually don't work with streams you
always work with a logical concept
called Dynamic tables so Dynamic tables
are similar to materialized views so the
basic principle is that you you create
your table so on the left side we have a
transaction table and on the right side
we have a revenue table and then you
define a
extending query up front and this query
is then translated into a topology and
executed to consume the changes that
come in from the left table and we'll
put it to the right table
so
I often get asked so is link SQL kind of
a database and my answer usually is no
it's not a database because you can
bring your own data and your own systems
we don't store data we are just
responsible kind of a hub between
systems and um yeah like you we don't
you don't have to change your entire
infrastructure just to use Flink and and
pipe data from one system to the other
um
so I mentioned it before
um that you work with Dynamic tables in
inflink but still under the hood there
are streams um in the engine right so
how can we actually map between tables
and streams and there is this
interesting concept called stream table
Duality which means you can actually go
back and forth between the two worlds
pretty easily
um without like affecting the semantics
and we'll also show you a example of
that shortly the important thing is that
sources operators and things in in fling
always work with changelogs under the
hood so a changed log usually contains
those four types of operations insert
update before update after and delete
update before can be skipped if there is
a primary key so if the operation is
item potent then you can just give the
update before and only work with the
update after but will also have an
example for that in general each
component declares what it consumes and
produces if a component only supports
plus I then it's appending or insert
only if it contains some kind of minus U
or minus D then it's updating
um if it contains a minus U we call this
retraction and if it never contains a
minus U but only a plus u then we call
this upserting so those are the general
terminologies
so let's have a concrete example so
again we have this as a standing query
we want to sum
transactions and and grouping by name so
let's have a new transaction come in so
we have Alice here
um
this would end up in in some change log
could be for example a Kafka like two
Kafka topics at the bottom and the upper
Parts basically represent what happens
if I would materialize or apply the
change log to some key value store or
two some to some database
so again so um we have our first sum and
we are putting this into the right table
that is easy then there is another a
record coming in this is Bob right and
we are putting it into the change log
the engine processes it computes the sum
and again updates the output table and
now comes the the important piece here
what happens if there is a second L is
coming in because now we need to
actually update the sum and the sum here
the total is actually not valid anymore
so what happens is that the engine will
actually emit a deletion update before
and to delete the old record and then it
will emit in update
to insert a new record
here we go
and yeah as you can see at the end it's
the same same result and yeah and then
if you want to save some traffic and you
can actually Define a primary key on the
sync then you can even
um you can even make a can save 50 of
the traffic in the downstream system by
just omitting the the update before
so we have a couple of connectors in
Flink so here is just like a an example
for some Source connectors that are
built in or like that blink provides
um and each of those connectors have
different different change lock modes so
for example if you just scan through a
file in in file system for example in S3
this will always create just insertions
um same for for Kafka regular Kafka is
just an insert only lock but like
confluent at some point also added like
the concept of absurd Kafka so absurd
Kafka is a special connector and emits
those kind of changes here and then
there is also jdbc by default inflink
jdbc is also just a scan of the T of the
table once so this also just produces
insert only changes and yeah if you want
to connect to the database via CDC
um connector then this is possible for
example with the Kafka connector but in
a division Json format that would be the
the maximum that you can do and then you
have all kinds of changes coming into
the into the engine and again the
optimizer tracks the mode the primary
Keys through the pipeline and then the
thing also declares what it can actually
Digest
so one more time why do we actually need
this distinguished distinct distinction
between a retract stream and an abstract
stream and here I have an example of a
account of account a SQL so I'm just I'm
Computing a histogram
um the nice property of about retract is
there is no primary key requirement so
you can also have a duplicate rows in in
your table or in your stream
so that basically also means that it
almost works for every external system
so the retract mode is actually the most
flexible mode in Flink it's also the
default mode
um so why is the retract mode necessary
so for this for this query here let's
assume we have two counts count one and
count two and there comes some record in
we don't care about the content actually
what we care about is like this we will
count this record so it will create a
one right the count one and then the
second count will be partitioned to some
subsequent operator and we will store
and state that count one has occurred
one time and what happens now if there
is a second row coming in
and now they're up to the count
um updates to two but like partitioning
wise it actually ends up at a different
subtask
um so we have at one in one state we
have one apps to one and the other one
two maps to one
um so we need to delete the other record
um in the other uh in the other subtask
and that's why why retraction is so
important
and uh upside is just an optimization
and sometimes it's not even possible to
use up search and then we need to use
retractions
um
you can also see this when you work with
link SQL
um for example in our SQL client and I
want to give you some some insights into
how you interpret the output of an
explain uh statement so again let's
assume we have a transaction table and
we have a payment table we assume that
both tables just have insert only
changes coming in and then we have a
result table which just accepts all
kinds of changes and um what we want to
calculate is just joining
um transaction and payment together
based on the transaction ID and yeah if
you if you run explain then you will see
this output here and the important thing
here is that it shows you basically what
the the changelup modes are so if
everything is input insertion
um then also the The Joint operator will
give you uh an insertion as an output
that's great so we have a fully append
only pipeline from source to sync
so now let's use an outer join for
example here so we're using left outer
join and the interesting thing is even
though the inputs are still insert only
the join operator now produces uh
produces retractions and why is that
because left join when the first record
comes in on on one of the sides
um
it actually will produce a null record
or null column for the other side until
the second side came in so we will emit
a null first and then later we have to
retract the null once we have matching
records so the join basically yeah
becomes like a retraction operator
can we make it better yes we can so for
example you can Define
primary keys on um on transaction and
and result
and and payment and with this
information at least we can scope it
down from
um from retraction stream
um to upside stream so that it already
improves the the performance um of the
query so in general
um
under the hood the um
the planner can actually change between
the modes if necessary so from append
only sometimes you can elect depending
on the operation you are creating an
updating table
um and um yeah depending on on the
operation sometimes the planner needs to
convert an updating table to a
retracting table and from a retracting
table back to an updating table
I don't want to go into the details here
but there is a lot of magic involved and
and sometimes people call the left side
streams and and the right side so
especially the upper one a table maybe
you know this from from K SQL but yeah
retraction mode is actually
um it's special and I don't know if
there is a corresponding
um a concept for other when or at other
vendors
um but in general
um we have a a lot of joint
implementations and in Flink so when you
just do a regular join it always uh
depends what is the input and then you
here you can see that the mode
transitions between a joint if it's just
a regular join between two append only
tables then you also get in the pen only
table out if this if there is one
updating
table as an input then you get an
updating table out if it's an outer join
I explained it already then you always
get an updating table out and then we
have like some special kind of join
which we call temporal join or stream
enrichment or time version joins so
there are very a lot of synonyms for
this which actually allows you to do
stream enrichment so an append only
table to enrich it with an updating
um table and the output is actually in a
pen only table and I also have brought
an example for this unfortunately we're
running out of time so I cannot explain
everything in details here because it
would take an entire day to talk about
all the stuff that you can do with fling
SQL but this is an example where you
basically in this case we want to join
some order table with some currency
rates table the currency rates they
update every millisecond or every second
or so and what you want to do is you
want want to calculate the conversion
rate or you want to have the order price
at the time when the order was placed so
even though the currency rates updates
frequently you want to join those two
tables based on time and you want to
have a view of the currency rate as of
the time when the order was was
happening and and this is this is
happening with the first system Time s
of uh as of clause
yeah I think that I have more examples
here
for example you can also do a an
explicit State a mode transition so if
you have an append only stream and you
actually want to create an updating view
out of it you can use an over window
with row number and there are some some
patterns that you can use in Flink
um to to basically create the right side
from the left side
yeah but yeah as I said I don't want to
go into the details I just want to show
you some very sophisticated examples of
what is what is possible with Flink and
now I also want to show you a little
demo this demo is also available and
there are way more examples in my GitHub
repository that you can just check out
and run in your IDE
and um so let's get started
um I brought a little CDC uh demo so
what I have here is a teleche project
um everything is runable within IntelliJ
I will start a Docker container now
um because I brought a my sequel
um database with me the mySQL database
is already filled with some value so I
have like this is the script so I have
uh yeah I have some where is it some
customer table and then I put some
example records with Alice Bob and and
Kyle into this table and I have a link
job here so I'm creating a stream
execution environment and a stream table
environment
um I have two tables registered because
you can approach this MySQL table from
two angles either you just scan it once
using the jdbc connector or you connect
to the CDC law and continuously process
the changes that are coming in so I'm
running this query now
so I'm just doing a select star from
transaction CDC so I'm I'm interested in
the live update of this table it takes
some time until
um the whole thing has started so here
you can see the program has not
terminated so it's it's constantly
watching for new updates coming in so
let's now insert a row into my SQL
and I could have used some of my SQL CLI
or so to to to to to
insert a new row but you can also use
Flink for that there is like Flink is
flexible enough to talk to
um
and talk to the database so I'm just
staying in the Flink world and I'm
executing SQL against the transactions
jdbc table so let me run this
it's a bit Overkill to run a link job
just for inserting a row but it's it's
possible
and once this job is finished then the
row is inserted into into my SQL and you
will also see that it immediately ends
up on the left side
detected by the CDC source
so um yeah we can also um
make this further another row
so that was the CDC lock and I just
wanted to show you also how for example
you can
make it more complicated so what about
if we want to read still from the
transaction CDC log but now we actually
want to enrich our transactions with
information from the customer uh
customer table and yeah we are making
this based on processing time so which
means we are basically
performing real-time lookups into the
MySQL table using the jdbc connector to
to perform a stream enrichment so um
I can also run this real quick
oops ah
demos
so so I'm inserting now a new customer
into into the customers table
and I'm restarting this job because
um we want to do the enrichment
and as you can see
so if I now so so now I have joined
those two records together based so Kyle
let me check it one more time
um so
um actually when I uh I messed up the
order actually so Kyle was actually
previously called Kyle and then changed
his name to Kylie and yeah when you run
this you would actually see on the left
side that uh like the table will show
you both Kyle and Kylie because based on
the on the on the time when the
transaction was happening Kyle was still
Kylie was still kyled called Kyle
um but yeah to try it out yourself it's
actually quite fascinating to have this
real-time lookups based on time
um
and there are way more examples online
um yeah so
a rough summary is uh think sql's Angel
is is a very very powerful changelog
processor has been developed for for
almost seven years now
um it is a very flexible tool for
integrating different systems with
different semantics and there is there
is way more I brought you some more SQL
examples just that you have seen them
once you can perform windowing you can
perform as I said time version joins you
can use the Met recognized Clause to to
do to do pattern matching and this
detect certain patterns in your table so
you can define something like a reg X so
here
kind of a record syntax to define a
different patterns and and then perform
calculations Downstream and there is
this very big ecosystem of CDC
connectors
um there is the special
sub-project CDC connectors that provide
you connectors for various databases
like Oracle postgres and so on and yeah
I think that's it from my side and if
you have any questions I'm ready to to
answer them now thank you
foreign